what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay what is up guys this is Rob and
today we are going to continue our
series on Omega level and Beyond Omega
level characters in the DC Universe in
today's video focuses on the wizard
Shazam now as a court of clarification
before we get started the wizard Shazam
takes the same name as Billy Batson
Shazam and it can get really really
confusing so in order to avoid any kind
of confusion we're just going to call
this guy the wizard now undoubtedly
people are probably asking the question
why are you not talking about Billy
Batson Shazam well the reason why is
because in order to understand his
character we have to do this character
and the reason why goes all the way back
to the idea that he's been around for 80
years and so predictably his origin has
changed multiple times since his debut
in whiz comics number two in 1940
originally the wizard was simply
intended to function as a plot device
for the character of Billy Batson in
order for him to receive his powers and
the origin that were presented with in
the early days of the character like
many artifacts of the Golden Age of
comic books is a little bit silly
so prior to meeting Billy Batson who's
basically a 12 year old homeless boy and
it was living down in a subway station
Billy had met a cloaked figure until the
two of them boarded a magical subway car
and traveled to an underground throne
room or just this ancient wizard just
sat hanging out the wizard eventually
tells Billy that his name is Shazam and
that he has been fighting evil for 3,000
years using the powers of the gods in
fact the name Shazam is actually an
acronym of the gods from which he
derives his powers explaining that the
wizard has the wisdom of Solomon the
strength of Hercules the 'cimmanon of
Atlas the courage of Achilles and the
speed of mercury a little bit of a irony
here neither Achilles nor Solomon are
actual gods Solomon is basically a
biblical king and Achilles is just a
really cool ancient reef warrior who was
played by Brad Pitt in whatever that
movie was I Kevin what that movie was
called Troy that's what it was
is there no one else forty years later
however DC decided that they wanted to
flush out the old Wizards origins so and
wolfs finest Comics number 262 in 1980
it was revealed that the wizard was at
one point in ordinary shepherd boy named
jebediah living in the land of Canaan
now after his parents were murdered by
her
nomads jebediah prayed to the gods not
to be left alone hearing his prayer the
gods chose jebediah to become their
champion and so Jedediah was renamed to
Blair him which was an anagram for the
first letters of the gods that imbued
him with their powers from our saj
jebediah receives strength from arrow
speed from river levy power from volt
our strength from EV Liam courage and
from Lu Miam he received wisdom there's
a 90% chance that I butchered the
absolute heck out of those names don't
care now after jebediah received a
portion of each of the Gods powers he
was transformed from a child into an
adult and was in tasked with using those
powers to battle the forces of evil in
the world now during this time the
wizard displayed an insane amount of
power just to get an idea of what sorts
of things he was capable of the wizard
was able to create a prison called the
rock of eternity which housed the three
faces of evil a demonic three head
dragon with magical abilities the
ability to breathe fire and corrupt the
minds of others to turn them evil now in
order to create the prison the wizard
had to acquire a rock formation from
heaven and one from hell so we're
dealing with a character who can enter
and leave Heaven and Hell freely and
bring parts of those otherworldly realms
back to earth why'd you want to bring
hell on earth I have no idea also in
addition to the three faces of evil the
wizard also captured the seven deadly
enemies of man wood you're basically
demons that represent the seven deadly
sins and simply imprison them within the
stone statues which are kept within the
walk of eternity itself now eventually
the wizard began to tire of his role as
a defender against all things evil and
began searching for someone to succeed
him as a champion his first choice was
actually an ancient Egyptian man named
Dwayne Johnson actually his name was
teth-adam now any time Adam said the
Wizards name he'd be granted the powers
of the gods but it originally given the
wizard his power although a would later
be retcon it was actually a pantheon of
Egyptian gods they gave Adam all the
abilities that he has in order to be
more in line with his Egyptian heritage
before long however Adam became
corrupted by his newfound power and
therefore the Wizards simply renamed him
to Black Adam and banished him to a
distant star now after Black Adam was
found unworthy the wizard sought out a
new successor and found one in the form
of Billy Batson who we mentioned earlier
who would basically be transformed into
a
named Shazam whenever he actually said
the name Shazam now in terms of how
powerful the wizard is he once served on
the quintessence which is basically a
Council of the most powerful beings in
the DC universe that included Zeus
ganthet of the guardians of the universe
hi father and the Phantom Stranger
serving alongside the wizard now the
function of this group was basically
just to monitor everything that was
going on in the DC Universe to ensure
that order is maintained but they don't
really interfere very often and usually
just observe at a distance and only
interfere when absolutely necessary now
the concept of the acht essence was
first introduced during the 1996 Kingdom
Come series which exists outside the
main DC continuity but they were later
brought into the main continuity as part
of Brand Morrison's run on JLA or
Justice League of America so we can
simply tell just by the fact that the
wizard is present on the council that
he's among the upper echelon of
characters in the DC Universe in terms
of power as he's placed here among those
beings that are considered to be
legitimate gods
now as for what powers the wizard
possesses well like most characters who
are going to be classified as a mega
level or beyond his powers are pretty
much anything he wants them to be and I
literally don't say that to be lazy
that's the way it is since the Wizards
powers are derived from divine sources
he's not bound by any of the limitations
of humanity meaning that he can survive
without air water or food of course he
also has your standard superhuman
abilities like strength speed agility
stamina and of course he can fly he has
an accelerated healing factor he's
virtually invulnerable to harm through
either physical or magical means he can
teleport he has a crazy amount of
willpower that allows him to persevere
in the most dire of situations and has
divine guidance that help him to make
decisions that will turn out in his
benefit the wizard is omnipresent
meaning he can be in multiple places at
one time as well as omniscient meaning
that he knows everything that he wants
to know and he can also read and
manipulate the minds of others he's
almost completely omnipotent due to how
advanced he is in the mystic arts and
because he's been around for nine
thousand years we can assume that he's
basically ageless another reason why I
say Aegis is because while he probably
would live forever if left to his own
devices that does not mean that he
cannot be killed in fact during the days
of vengeance many
series written by Bill Willingham in
2005 we saw an epic battle between the
wizard and another of DC's most powerful
entities the spectre who basically
serves as God's arm of vengeance within
the DC Universe there was a video
previously where I referred to the
spectre as like the the arm of God's
wrath or something like that that is not
the spectre that is somebody else at
Evan what their name is
and they basically took over the body of
Maxwell Lord during the events of
Justice League versus Suicide Squad
it's really weird and so while
eventually the wizard got the better of
the spectre and appeared to have
defeated him this Specter was able to
revive himself and kill the wizard by
siphoning off his power and so because
of this we know that the wizard can be
killed at least by other insanely
powerful beings however we're only going
to draw this conclusion insofar as we're
referring to the Wizards physical body
as we later learn that the widgett
spirit had survived but had been trapped
within the rock of finality which is
pretty much the polar opposite of the
walk of eternity now with the help of
the flash Jay Garrick Billy Batson
releases the wizard from the rock and
he's fully restored when Black Adam
gives the wizard his power so the wizard
can save his wife now the funny thing is
that's really all we see when it comes
to the wizard before the new 52 when DC
effectively rebooted their entire
continuity but his depiction during the
new 52 is actually a little bit
different in his first new 52
appearances he simply just shows up as
one of several Wizards who were on a
council of wizards that exists to
control the magic on earth and punish
those who abuse it the only other time
that we saw him besides that was during
Darkseid war when it's revealed that
he's actually a god named ma'am again to
enlist a whole new pantheon of gods to
empower Billy Batson but again this guy
is kind of crazy in terms of his
abilities the problem is that when it
comes to the wizard his appearances are
for the most part limited because
remember when it came to the wizard as a
character the star of the comic was
Billy Batson not really the wizard
himself but I thought it'd be kind of
cool to do this get my hand in a more
obscure character to see what happens
it's kind of one of those weird
situations but if you guys are new here
to come this explain make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the robb cork if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
plus down in the comment section let me
know who you guys want me to do next
most likely we might transition back to
a Marvel character real quick and then
we'll
jump back over to DC what I'd like to do
is give them the habit of alternating so
one Marvel one DC one Marvel one DC grab
some other characters are like valiant
image do like an omega-level mutant
surround sorry an omega-level character
like spawn or something along those
lines but let me know what you guys want
to see and I will catch you all later
please
[Music]
you